>> ♪ ♪
>> THE MEMBERS OF THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
STEADY RESOLVE.
I THANK THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN CHUCK GRASSLEY FOR HIS
WISDOM AND FAIRNESS.
I GIVE SPECIAL GRATITUDE TO
SENATORS SUSAN COLLINS, JOE
MANCHIN AND JOE KYLE.
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THEY ARE A CREDIT TO THE COUNTRY
AND THE SENATE.
I WILL FOREVER GRATEFUL TO EACH
OF THEM AND TO ALL OF THE
SENATORS WHO CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED MY NOMINATION.
>> Sean: THAT WAS BRETT
KAVANAUGH THANKING MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE INCLUDING MY NEXT
GUEST LINDSEY GRAHAM.
I DON'T THINK THIS WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT YOU.
THE MOMENT WHERE IT WAS JUST
ORGANIC FOR YOU WAS
EXTRAORDINARILY POWERFUL
INASMUCH AS IT WAS RIGHTEOUS
INDIGNATION.
I DON'T THINK IT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED -- I WATCHED THE SPEECH
OF SUSAN COLLINS.
I THINK IT WAS THE BEST SPEECH I
HAVE EVER SEEN.
LAYING OUT THE CASE WITH NO
INFLUENCE OUTSIDE FROM ANYBODY
UNDER ENORMOUS PRESSURE.
I HAVE HEARD EVER HORRIBLE THING
SAID ABOUT THIS WOMAN.
WHERE IS THEIR SENSE OF DECENCY
AND DIGNITY?
IF YOU PLAY OUT AN INTELLIGENT
CASE BUT YOU HAPPEN TO DISAGREE.
>> WELL, IT'S ABOUT OUTCOMES FOR
OUR FRIENDS ON THE LEFT.
THERE IS NOTHING THEY WON'T DO
TO MAINTAIN POWER.
TO TAKE IT BACK WHEN THEY LOSE
IT.
SUSAN COLLINS REPRESENTED THE
BEST AND EXPLAINED WHAT SHE DID.
THE PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE
WERE GOING TO DESTROY KAVANAUGH
IF HE LET THEM.
MY INTERVENTION HELPED A GOOD
MAN WHO WAS BEING RAILROADED AND
HUMILIATED, I AM PLEASED.
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP THANKS FOR
STICKING BY BRETT.
BRETT, THANK FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE TO STAY IN THERE WHEN A
LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD QUIT.
I AM GRATEFUL TO BRETT KAVANAUGH
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: I SEE IN PEOPLE A LEVEL
OF ENERGY AND ENTHUSIASM AND
JUST RAW, WE WON'T PUT UP WITH
THIS!
I THINK IT'S IGNITED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW THE IMPACT IT WILL
HAVE ON THE COUNTRY IN 29 DAYS.
CONSIDERING THIS WE SEE EVERY 2
TO 4 YEARS AND EVERY
CONFIRMATION THESE TACTICS, WE
CAN'T REWARD THIS BEHAVIOR
BECAUSE WE WILL GET A LOT MORE
OF IT.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT SUSAN WAS
UNDERSTANDING.
IF SHE LEGITIMIZE THIS PROCESS,
GOD HELP THE NEXT PERSON
NOMINATED FOR THE SUPREME COURT.
WHAT WAS INSULTING IS THE WAY
THAT THE SENATOR FROM HAWAII
TOOK EVERYTHING WE HOLD NEAR AND
DEAR TO US --
>> Sean: SHE SAID MEN SHOULD
SHUT UP AND SIT DOWN.
THAT GOES FOR ME TOO.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S PROBABLY RIGHT HALF THE
TIME.
THE PEOPLE AT SOUTH CAROLINA
GAVE ME MY VOICE AND NOT THE
SENATOR FROM HAWAII.
I SAID WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
THINKING.
SENATOR COLLINS GAVE THE BEST
EXPLANATION WHY A REASONABLE
PERSON WOULD VOTE FOR JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
WE WILL TAKE THIS TO THE BALLOT
BOX 29 DAYS NOW FROM.
YOU HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE
AMERICA.
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE YOU ARE GUILTY UNTIL
PROVEN INNOCENT BECAUSE YOU ARE
A REPUBLICAN?
OR LIVE IN THE SUSAN COLLINS
WORLD WHERE YOU ARE HEARD AND
LISTENED TO AND EVALUATED?
>> Sean: SENATOR, I HAVE BEEN IN
THIS GAME -- STARTING MY 23rd
YEAR AT FOX TONIGHT.
AND 30 YEARS ON RADIO.
I AM BEEN LUCKY.
WAITING FOR IT ALL TO COME
CRASHING DOWN LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE.
>> YOU ARE GOOD TO GO.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PROGRESS WE MADE AS A COUNTRY, I
HAVE NOT HEARD ONE IDEA FROM THE
OTHER SIDE THAT WILL IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE THAT MATTER
THE MOST.
THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH CAROLINA AND
THE PEOPLE IN THE REST OF THIS
COUNTRY THAT ARE SEEING THE
ECONOMY BOOM, OUR SECURITY
BEEFED UP IN WAYS WE NEVER
IMAGINED JUST 2 SHORT YEARS AGO.
>> WELL, THERE ARE 2 ISSUES IN
THIS ELECTION.
EVERYTHING ELSE HAS GONE BY THE
WAY SIDE.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH WHAT THEY DID
TO KAVANAUGH?
IS THIS THE AMERICA YOU WANT TO
PASS ON TO YOUR CHILDREN?
WE WANT WOMEN TO BE HEARD AND
RESPECTEDED.
DR. FORD WAS HEARD AND
RESPECTFULLY TREATED.
WE WANT A CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS
THAT PROTECTS ALL OF US.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
WELL, IF WE LOSE, YOU HAVE A LOT
TO LOSE.
YOU WILL HAVE A SMALLER MILITARY
AND BIGGER GOVERNMENT.
IF THEY WIN YOU WILL HAVE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ORGANIZED AROUND THE IDEA OF
HATING TRUMP.
THERE IS A LOT TO LOSE IF YOU
TURN OVER POWER TO MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES.
THERE IS A LOT TO LOSE IN THIS
ELECTION.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Sean: SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM,
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT YOU.